[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé
21000 lits fermés depuis 2017 démission
de personnel services d'urgence saturés
sont les symptômes de la crise profonde
que traverse nos hôpitaux notamment dans
nos territoires ruraux et le
plafonnement de la rémunération des
médecins intérimaires qui va entrer
comme vous le savez en vigueur dans
quelques jours risque de déstabiliser un
peu plus nos hôpitaux en sous-effectif
ma question portera plus spécifiquement
sur le manque d'investissement dont
souffre nos hôpitaux en effet
l'investissement hospitalier a été
divisé par deux en 10 ans que ce soit à
Vienne à Pithiviers ou encore à Vichy
dans ma circonscription l'état des
bâtiments hospitaliers est indigne à
l'hôpital de Vichy un garde-corps et
même tombé du troisième étage du
bâtiment de pédopsychiatrique qui est en
état de délabrement
mais ce qui est choquant monsieur le
ministre c'est que de nombreux hôpitaux
connaissent un manque de des ARS tout
simplement parce que leur situation
financière est jugée trop saine lors du
Ségur l'hôpital de Vichy n'a pas pu
bénéficier pleinement des aides à la
reprise de dette uniquement parce qu'il
n'atteignait pas le taux d'endettement
requis et à ce jour le projet de
construction du nouveau bâtiment
principal est toujours en attente du
soutien financier de la RS visiblement
dans le système actuel on préfère
sanctionner les bons élèves monsieur le
ministre plus que de des plans à
répétition nos hôpitaux ont besoin
aujourd'hui d'une ressource budgétaire
pérenne et dédiée à l'investissement
comme l'a d'ailleurs recommandé la
commission d'enquête du Sénat alors ma
question sera simple comptez-vous enfin
un furet un financement stable suffisant
mais surtout équitable entre les
différents hôpitaux de nos territoires